venu le temps des cathédrales
si la cathédrale notre dame de paris a
autant inspiré les artistes du xxème
siècle c'est en grande partie grâce au
roman de victor hugo écrit en 1831 pas
la dissocier victor hugo c'est
hallucinant de voir le caractère
visionnaire
une fois de plus de ce grand homme que
tu es victor hugo dans son livre
l'écrivain raconte l'histoire d'amour
est possible du bossu quasimodo pour la
belle gitane esmeralda à travers son
roman
victor hugo dénoncé le piteux état la
cathédrale et lançait même un appel à sa
restauration
plus de cent cinquante ans plus tard
richard cocciante t il de plamondon
on en tire une comédie musicale qui a
aiguisé par plus de 10 millions de
spectateurs
l'histoire a aussi été adapté au cinéma
disney en a fait plusieurs films
[Musique]
il faut dire merci à victor hugo parce
que son oeuvre notre-dame de paris à
prêter à toutes les sauces a été adapté
au cinéma très fréquemment
indépendamment de victor hugo la
cathédrale notre dame de paris a marqué
l'histoire du cinéma
en devenant un des premiers lieux filmés
par les frères lumière les pionniers du
cinéma
la cathédrale a été le décor de
plusieurs films comme le fabuleux destin
d'amélie poulain l'automne dernier pour
une rare fois l'intérieur de la
cathédrale a servi de lieu de tournage
de films de fiction une comédie
romantique de la cinéaste valérie
donzelli sur ce film qui a été fait
effectivement autour de notre dame est à
l'intérieur semble-t-il de la cathédrale
va passer subitement quand il va sortir
en 2019 du statut de comédies légères à
document historique la cathédrale notre
dame de paris est une oeuvre d'art en
soi un chef-d'oeuvre architectural de
grands maîtres de la peinture l'ont
immortalisé notamment marc chagall
salvador dali henri matisse et gustave
loiseau elle a marqué l'imaginaire
collectif et celui de patrick bruel de
passage à montréal la nouvelle la
secourir ces tristes de risque et à ses
fours et que par c'est d'être si peu
préparé à ça ici julie jasmin boudreau
radio canada montréal